quand on nous a annoncé qu'on devait
fermer à minuit oui bien entendu c'était
un choc
le choc du confinement a fini par passer
au fil des semaines après plus d'un mois
à l'arrêt total
stéphane jégo le chef propriétaire de
l'ami jean à dépoussiérer ses casseroles
c'est devant emporter les les fruits et
légumes épicerie vendant mais là il
faisait des médias qu'on doit apprendre
entre la bande pour emporter et les
produits de la ferme il y tester
différentes formules
mais il est loin d'être convaincu que ça
puisse être financièrement viable
aujourd'hui à bientôt
il ne se sent pas prêt à rouvrir les
portes de son petit restaurant pour
autant par rapport à la proximité qu'on
a dans nos établissements nous ce qu'ils
nous disent qu'on craignait que la
majorité de notre profession c'est de
créer une bombe sanitaire et ça on
n'avait pas envie d'être responsable
d'une deuxième quand amy et surtout
d'être obligé de refermer ne se remettre
en confinement
il est rassuré que le gouvernement
refuse pour le moment de dire quand
pourront rouvrir les restaurants les
bars et les cafés tant que l'aide
financière spéciale octroyés au secteur
est maintenu mieux vaut ne rien
bousculer dit il c'est comme un coma
artificiel car on a eu la chance d'avoir
des mesures exceptionnelles sur le
chômage partiel mais on est sur des
charbons alain fontaine maître
restaurateur lui croit que certains
établissements pourraient rouvrir leurs
portes de façon sécuritaire dès
maintenant
les grands restaurants les fameuses
étoiles et et de plus grandes salles
comme la sienne mais beaucoup peu
importe la date ne pourrons pas survivre
selon lui est ce qu'on est prêt nous
s'il faut retirer vous voyez ces tables
à elles sont très proches donc si je
retire une table je divise en 2 bat
salle donc déjà y aura moins d'ambiance
mais on peut le faire je ne rentre salle
mais pensez qu'il ya des bistrots c'est
trop couvert donc si vous enlevez 15
couverts à cette rencontre vous avez
plus qu 1 de couverts dans la salle le
modèle économique ne fonctionne pas les
experts dans leurs pires commentaires
pense à 40 à 50% de restaurants qui
disparaîtrait
combien j'ai dans ma dans ma tirelire
pour moi vivre donner à manger à mes
enfants
c'est le sujet on a déjà été lessivés
par les mouvements de gilet jaune puis
les mouvements sociaux du mois de
novembre décembre dernier je peux tenir
très peu de temps le petit rétro d'un
pas de clients des gorilles et
propriétaire du petit rétro un
établissement qui a ouvert ses portes en
1904 lui aussi se dit qu'il faudra se
réinventer pour survivre et vite
mais chez lui c'est beaucoup plus qu'un
bon plat chaud qu'on vient chercher
et ça ça se place difficilement dans un
contenant de plastique
on vient pour l'ambiance et ce
restaurant d'ailleurs avait une hymne
qui s'appelle la vie d'avant on était
terriblement prémonitoire le tir et
ronak des amis depuis tokyo bobigny
on vient et met la vie d'avant je suis
le passeur c'est un restaurant plein
d'histoires comment moi qui ai repris le
flambeau de ce restaurant je ne
réussirais pas et je serai impuissant à
tenir et elle fait revivre encore des
générations
ça me rend ça me rend fou
trop de tristesse antoine fontaine ne
dort pas beaucoup mieux
il ne descend plus aux cuisines il n'a
pas le courage d'y mettre les pieds
les pertes pour lui comme pour tant
d'autres sont loin de se résumer à un
simple calcul comptable les lieux de
portage des lieux de vivre ensemble cet
art de vivre
moi je veux laisser mes enfants ça j'ai
pas leur laisser la peine que j'aide que
mon restaurant soit fermé je vais pas
leur laisser le licenciement que je vais
à le voir faire pour certains des
employés genre l'essai on a connu cette
cochonnerie de virus et on a tenu bon et
on a sauvé une autre angoisse
l'empêchent de terminer y quand le
moment sera venu de redémarrer les
fourneaux les français seront ils au
rendez vous quand tout le monde sera
ouvert qui pensent à nous quoi qui nous
oublie pas parce que on les a pas
oubliés et et on a besoin tout voilà
voilà c'est terminé
il s'est marié ève bédard radio canada